- I can't...uh, pay rent with these...things.
-One's a pumpkin and these Asgardian coins they're not worth anything.
-In Asgard, those coins, these coins are worth a gazillion human dollars, ok?
-There's a gazillion, you're rich.
-There's a gazillion, gazillion, gazillion, gazillion.
- No one will exchange these.
-Go to the market, set up a store right?
- Yeah.
Yeah
- Asgardian Wear.  Previously owned by Thor.  I'm a celebrity.  That will sell like hot cakes.
- You might need to think about getting a j..getting a job.
- Get a job? You serious?
-Yeah
- I have a job!  You know what my job is?  I save the planet.
- Yeah.
- Maybe you should get a job. Hmm?
- I have a job.
- Really? (Mocks typing on a keyboard)  Hitting the machine with the words that come out of it?
- You know I have a job.
- "Ooh, this is knowledge, knowledge is power."  No it's not, knowledge is not power.  That's power.
- The brain is a muscle, and that's a muscle, and that's a muscle, and they're all muscles.  This is all muscle, so I
- I'm covered in brains and I've more brains than you.
-So you think maybe we could just think about...
- I think we need a servant.
- I don't think we can get a servant.
- We should get a servant.
- We can't...I...don't think we can get a servant.
- Yay! It's settled! We're getting a servant!
- Marvel's Doctor Strange.  On Digital and Blu-ray.